- I don't have a lot of
experience with bubble blowing.
This sounds so weird.
Sandy wouldn't say that.
(upbeat jazz music)
- I'm very competitive.
So, if this is like a
competition between me
and the other Pink Ladies, and the boys,
I'm gonna win it.
- I'm really nervous about
this bubble blowing situation.
- Are there any rules?
If a hole starts coming
can I like put a...
(jazz music)
What's the technique?
- I think the last time I did it
I was probably like 10, so I don't know.
- I'm from the South, I have a good
southern blowing technique.
- You have to make sure
you get it to the point
where the sugar isn't at the top.
- I need to find my inner bubble peace.
- You got to chew it for a long time.
I'm not quite ready to do it yet.
(laughing)
(upbeat jazz music)
(classic rock music)
- I'm competitive, I play to win, sorry.
Don't apologize Jordan, here we go.
(classic rock music)
- Nope.
- What? What?
- How it goin' to fail me like this.
After all I just did, I got
embarrassed by my own skills.
(classic rock music)
- Oh, what is going on?
(bell ringing)
- I don't know what Julianne's secret is,
I think she lucked out, I think she gets
the jackpot on everything,
she's beautiful, she's talented.
(classic rock music)